you guys we love athletic greens
athletic greens is 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right and to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticreens.com Tuesday again that's
athleticgreens.com Tuesday to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
whether you're starting small or scaling
up ship station makes ship happen
ship more and grow more with shipstation
go to shipstation.com today and sign up
with promo code trash Tuesday for a free
60-day trial start today and get set up
before the biggest shipping season of
the year that's two months free visit
shipstation.com Click the microphone at
the top and type in code trash Tuesday
we spent a lot of time
in our beds okay whether it's watching
horrific news days if it's anime anime
uh if it's uh videos your
boyfriend make you squirt yeah even if
it's your boyfriend doing everything in
bed as well as out of bed
that's why it's important to make sure
you've got the best mattress and that
mattress is Helix if you're nervous
about buying a mattress online don't be
Helix sleep has over 12 000 5 Star
reviews for a reason their two-minute
sleep quiz matches you with a mattress
that's a perfect fit plus you have a
hundred nights to try it out risk-free
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at Helix sleep.com slash
trash Tuesday hi you guys I hope you
enjoyed this episode I know I did I just
want to let you know I'm doing stand-up
I'm coming to Phoenix San Francisco
Seattle and Portland you can get tickets
at Esther onice.com and my solo podcast
my pleasure drops every Thursday morning
can't wait for you guys to see what it's
like you guys the time is here my
favorite most exciting date uh coluso
Casino come Gamble and party with me you
know I love to gamble that is on
September 30th one night only then next
month you can see me in Kansas City
um Irvine and then I'm gonna hold a
bunch of other places go to
annieleterman.com shows foreign
[Music]
you guys we are very excited to finally
have this guest on our show she is from
one of our favorite alcohol to Sister
podcast Girls Gotta Eat welcome Ashley
hesseltine did I say your last name
right it's hustleton
and the tine of it all is very yeah like
Valentine you can relate Lederman
Letterman I know I'm such a natural
leader that people always think it's
Lederman but it's Letterman and then
your last name's a nightmare I don't
know I was gonna just it's a night I
don't know why I thought that would be I
don't think anyone in this room has
gotten my last name right not once oh
thank you Carlos oh it's so disgusting
wait I didn't even know that I don't
want it to be yeah it's cue not [ __ ]
yeah it's cune I guess it's racial
slurrency way less races I don't know is
it racist if you don't even know it's a
[ __ ] slur who is it against raccoons
are we gonna start doing the origin
story of slurs for us but that's
actually not about it that's maybe
patreon paywall
um but actually welcome thank you to
trash Tuesday we're very excited to have
you to be here
um thank you I was listening to your
show and I so you're like a reader
you're like a big reader I am yeah I'm
great at reading and I read a lot that's
so rude to say you obviously don't watch
the show that's so mean you'll be like
I'm a great reader are you guys are you
all bad readers I'm literally unable to
read it the ad reads are pretty
difficult
well my co-host is that like we had this
joke that one time she read something so
good and I genuinely said Raina great
job reading and like our audience loved
it they started saying like great job
reading
like she we it's it's a thing she's open
about it like I'm I'm an exceptional
reader I'm so sorry if this that's okay
no I want you to shine
she knows she's not so even like when we
do live shows on stage like we have to
read something she's like this is really
long I have to let Ashley handle that
you know I'm the Ashley I mean I'm the
I'm I'm not the Ashley Lorena
um but I do read a lot of like I've
started just reading more books I love
the way you talk about books because you
sound like an addict but for books
because you're like whenever someone
posted photo I buy it right away like
you just you had like the energy that I
bring to like different flavored
breakfast cereals yeah like for books
and I was like Wow could it could be
that way it's it's been I've been
reading more recently but I I grew up
like a big book kid my mom was a
librarian like it's just a like big book
energy I don't know did you get a lot of
like book fair toys where you're always
getting a lot of like erasers shaped
like ice cream and stuff yeah I mean I
saw this meme recently that was like do
you remember the Scholastic Book Fair
and they named all the things you could
get there and they made mention of the
Lamborghini poster do you remember there
would be like random posters did you
guys have that I didn't grow up here oh
I was upset I had it the book fair what
are they for someone who doesn't read
the book fair was alive it was lit okay
I like what I was one do you remember
the books though that had like wait
let's explain it to kalila first so the
Scholastic Book Fair is when like you go
to school one day and the gym is all set
up like a huge bookstore oh we had that
in the Philippines and Esther was like
this is incredible I don't have to work
out and you could buy little things here
and there okay yes I remember it was so
much but then and then they would award
that week they would award The Bookworm
of the year which was always my sister
well this is like a really deep cut did
you guys have Pizza Hut reading club or
whatever
I had pizza I don't know where you grew
up like I lived grew up in the east
coast yeah like you had this thing and
if you've read a certain amount of books
you would go get a personal pan pizza oh
my God how exciting and that was back
when Pizza had had the salad bar like it
was like a night out were you doing
salad bar though as a kid I also feel
like I grew up in like the Wendy's salad
bar oh I loved it do you remember wait
do you remember when there was the bread
the garlic bread and it was just the it
was the bun sliced in half and it was
everything I've ever wanted in my life
yes they had like a pasta like people
don't know where are you from on the
East Coast I'm from Delaware Delaware
okay this sort of lines up with this
theory that my dad taught me when I was
younger he said that people get smarter
as you go east like everyone on the west
coast is dumber and then they get
smarter and smarter and then the
smartest people are on the East Coast so
that would make that would track the
best readers I live on the east coasts
you you don't help the theory
but then also but then like far like
West like
San Francisco like all those numbers you
know yeah look it's just what you mean
look it's just the spirit of it also
it's weird you guys brought out Pizza
Hut because I of course just saw Tick
Tock about how kale the biggest
purchaser of kale was originally Pizza
Hut and it was decoration for the salad
bar yeah and then some lady was like I'm
a fan of kale and she like rebranded
kale so all us idiots would eat it that
makes sense because kale holds well it
doesn't Wilt it was just literally like
Golden Corral Decor like it's wild to
remember it looks like the the Rolling
Hills of uh I'm so inspired by this
Rebrand I'm like if kale can go from
like the Pizza Hut Golden Corral garbage
decoration like and then become like the
health Trend food like what well it's
like well it's like lobster lobsters
where the Bottom Feeders they were like
they gave them to the prisoners and
stuff and now it's like one of the most
expensive items well lobsters are also
um they're they're seasoned I think is
coming to an end I you know I gather
Lobster you murder you're making them go
extinct well every year I gather Lobster
from the ocean I dive and I grab lobster
right but then you [ __ ] out Gilbert this
[ __ ] sent me this article about how
lobsters actually not only are sentient
but they feel depression no no no no and
so you don't talk about this when you
when they lose like a part of their
let's say for example because they bond
for life they bond for Life we've all
heard them scream it's like look you
just don't pay attention to that part
and then you just dip them in butter
that's got to be a good life to just
make other people happy you're depressed
what do you want put out everybody's
looking forward they're biologically
um Immortal so they don't die you can
they cannot die unless someone actually
kills them
um but they will live on forever what so
it we're kind of just like killing like
relics basically or like ancestors is
how I see it but with there's going to
be an overpopulation because they would
never die we're helping the world oh
true don't take my Lobster really and
also bring me some [ __ ] I'm reading
that lobsters do seek out safe spaces
when they're stressed probably in the
corner of the little thing kalila do
coach them and you go like you go I'll
listen to your problems over here a
little lobster oh my god oh you're not
feeling good today I come on over here
you can be any gendered you want over
here and you just spear them to spear I
don't spare them we'll save space yeah
but anyways well I think about they
that's the friends quote right Phoebe
said they oh yeah it's her Lobster yeah
yeah yeah they mate for life that's why
you got to kill them both at the same
time it's like the notebook
their life okay I just have you guys
like vegan or no no no I'm about to do
all me I'm like I'm this close to
believing that vegetables are poisoned I
listen to One podcast then I listen to
another one and I'm like it's making a
lot of sense here guys plants are
killing us salads scary and dangerous I
eat everything my pear parents are have
been vegan for four years and I'm
getting a little stressed out about it
and I need them to eat eggs
um what are what about you I eat
everything I don't I don't eat a lot of
pork I think that like oh yeah I just
chose an animal to not eat you know and
it's my least favorite so I steer away
from pork but every I eat everything
else and then my parents are pescetarian
which is like totally manageable when
you were growing up they were like that
or they it started like maybe when I
went off to college yeah like a couple
years back but they finally had the
courage yeah because we grew up eating
like sloppy joes yeah you know is there
a specific type of I think you might be
the same type of trash I am wait wait
where are you from Philadelphia oh I
mean so yeah Delaware is like a suburb
of Philly so it is I mean basically
basically uh so yeah they but it's it's
fine like I just I don't know I couldn't
do I couldn't give up like the dairy I
think it's so difficult okay have you
ever been married no okay do you have
ever like imagine a wedding do you have
like a do you think you're gonna go
classy or are you gonna go like sloppy
joes are you gonna go like an in and out
truck or like caviar not no seated like
plated dinner yes I think it's like some
sort of buffet but it's like really good
food like I could see like a taco bar or
I went to a wedding that was breakfast
food
breakfast all day what a dream yeah it
was good because I I it's at six in the
morning wake up [ __ ]
yeah it was cheaper in the morning
um I I don't think I've been to weddings
that are really fancy that were like
Stephen Starr catered and it's just
never good like you can't banquet food
is not good for the masses that's just
too much it's not gonna be good I have a
question do people not ever do morning
weddings is that not a thing maybe like
another that would go along with one of
the things I do want to do which is a
pajama themed wedding or a sleepover
wedding oh my God
I thought you wanted to do a lesbian
themed wedding or was just you marrying
a woman
I think that'll have to be the second
marriage
um what if we did like late weddings I
think a good idea is to do like a
midnight wedding so then you don't have
to invite like old like you can just be
like all right no kids yes no kids like
faster bedtime like you're a bad parents
yeah make it really hard for everyone to
get there it's on a weird Island and
there's only one Ferry yeah it's a rave
wedding yeah oh yeah or even at 2 A.M
then you basically eliminate the thought
of people bringing their kids yeah you
have to take mine you can't be you can
have your kids at a Molly yeah either
caffeinated or mollied up you better be
both you better be both I know that
you're a main drug of choice is books
but yeah I've gotten Miss branded that's
okay do you have other vices like I'm
basically a newly a pothead so I'm just
curious if what your deal is if you do
that too and she means pot not a pod
she's not like just getting into
podcasts I really love yoga no um I I
mean I I drink and I stay up late and
I'm on my phone too much and I don't
I've just never done really great with
with weed like edible specifically like
I'll smoke a little weed here and there
but I feel like I'm off all other drugs
because I'm terrified of fentanyl mm-hmm
no more powders like I I just I haven't
done a ton of Coke but I've
I would be like sure if I'm in the mood
and it's out but I feel so scared yeah
it's like if they asked twice I'm always
like I'm always like no I don't want to
do coconut you sure I'm like okay
twice but I don't know I don't have like
a ton of advice I mean it's so boring
but I just the thing that I'm always
trying to work on is just like not being
on my phone yeah
do you have any moves well I I have been
leaving my phone outside of my bedroom
it has helped has any have you ever
missed anything where you're like [ __ ] I
missed something well I like turn my
ringer off at night oh good and then
just just so they don't interrupt when
you're candy crushing or whatever yeah
Tick Tock but I think it's helped I
think that like you when you're really
trying to scroll right before bed it's
like lighting up your brain and so it's
like I'm not an also neurologist but it
just isn't good you're not a neurologist
why are you here what's going on I quit
med school or even if it's the first
thing you pick up if first thing in the
morning so like my rule is always first
30 minutes yeah as my eyes are cracking
open I will not look at my phone I'll
take my dogs out do my thing and then
pick up my phone afterwards it pisses
people off because they're like why
where were you oh it's really healthy
yeah well I need it and also the wear
worry is I'm done with the where we're
used I have no more where were you in my
life yeah no no no if you're where was I
go [ __ ] yourself
anything that's whatever I wanted to be
doing you just have to say like
boundaries in self-care these days and
like it's fine I mean you guys know you
live in California like right is that
that's our thing no one can fight you on
it yeah you'd be surprised
wait so Esther sent me this thing
yesterday
um about
um looking for the best or it's a hack
to look for the best Chinese food in
your area is to look for the Chinese
restaurant that has specifically 3.5
Stars not four stars not three stars 3.5
it sounds like a prank or like a joke
but then the way he explains it you're
like wait this is mathematical like
really are we watching it easiest way to
find authentic Chinese food assuming
you're living in a major metropolitan
area is to go on Yelp and look for
restaurants with three and a half Stars
exactly three and a half not three not
four three and a half stars is the sweet
spot for authentic Chinese food PF
Chang's two and a half Stars bad
obviously obviously bad the entire Fung
four stars too many stars too many white
people like it the service is too good
by the ways here are better I've been
here the waiters are not going to pay
attention to you they're going to be
rude but it's going to taste better so
I'm talking about three and a half stars
that orange 3.5 that's exactly what you
want why is this the case here's my
theory cultural expectations for service
are different in Asia that's not as
proactive they're not going to to come
up to you they're not going to just
proactively give you refills you need to
flag down the waiters people on Yelp are
insufferable they're digging in all
these restaurants the service is bad
however the food balances it out so you
end up at three and a half Stars it's a
sweet spot trust me brilliant easiest
way amazing can you look up this place
in in New York called New Moon so this
is like my order place but I have no
idea what what it's like the food is so
good delivered
so now I'm just so curious if it passes
the test I'm nervous you guys oh it's a
4.1
the food is so good but I I literally
don't know where it is I'm trying to get
a vibe off this photo but um it kind of
looks like [ __ ] in the right way you
know right if it makes you feel better
his example didn't taifung for four
stars is my favorite restaurant of all
right it is and it is for white people
that means uh dumb I saw this meme the
other day that said having a restaurant
reservation is so embarrassing like hi
I'm here for my spaghetti appointment
damn
so funny like it when you think about
stuff like that that cuts me to my core
I'm a rose girl now because I've been
burned too many times oh for sure yeah
I've been burning I did get to slip
someone money once then that felt good I
like slipping money I also have to say
that Ambiance I don't give a [ __ ] about
don't give a [ __ ] about it just the food
I wish that I was some like culturally
special smart person that like cared
what the restaurant looked like I just
want the good food the view is fun
though it was fun I like a Vibe I like
like music they just don't get it right
sometimes I'm like weird about music and
it's like I would have to agree with you
on that like I I don't know like I I
think that it's important but then also
like it's not like they're playing the
hits at the Chinese place they really do
though but they do yeah that's a problem
like if you go to any Asian restaurant
they always have the most nostalgic
playlist so you're like I haven't heard
this but it's your mom's playlist that's
true that you're saying that is actually
so perfect because I went to a Japanese
restaurant with Todd and they were
playing all this like Thai music that
his mom always used to play and Thai
dance can you look up Ty dancing maybe
Laos dancing it's like I can do
I'm like a dance I can do
yeah it's starting to get a little
complicated
dances that you think they're easy like
the cuff it dance I'm like I could do
that and then I tried I was like it's
not which one's the coffee I tried over
the weekend I could do it wait what's
that [ __ ] do it it's the fiance cuff It
song show it it's the show it Esther has
been able to teach it it's very easy
answer you've got it people sometimes
have problems with the body roll right
so it's basically it's this volume
yeah that's not that easy that might be
the only thing I can do
so you guys take athletic greens like
every day right one scoop every single
morning I don't have to think about
whether or not I'm gonna get my vitamins
and minerals throughout the day it's one
and done I love the way it tastes I
don't start my day without it I shake it
up in the little Shaker I use my little
matcha stirrer yeah it's delicious cold
water it's so good I just love that it's
something that everyone universally
agrees is like that one way to get
everything that you need in in one Fell
Swoop and instead of having to do the
math of how much do I need of this and
that and buying a bunch of different
things you buy it all in one place with
athletic greens I mean contrary to what
people might think I'm actually like not
a great swallower so it's hard sometimes
to have 10 million vitamins to choke
down this throat but I didn't know were
you having a moment I was throwing up
and thinking about me you said you're
not swelling no I um
I can't take pills either so I need
powders and I'm so grateful athletic
greens actually doesn't taste bad like
it has a nice taste and it's so much
easier it just makes life easier is what
it does and with one delicious scoop of
athletic greens you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Food
store superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help start your day rates
basically you're investing in an
all-in-one nutritional
insurance and it's lifestyle friendly
whether you eat keto paleo dairy free
vegan it only contains less than one
gram of sugar no GMOs all of the nasty
stuff yeah and it costs less than three
dollars a day so you're investing in
your health and it's cheaper than your
cold brew and right now it's time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into the flu and cold
season it's just one scoop in a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com Tuesday again that's
athleticgreens.com Tuesday to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
I have to say having an online business
is both easy fun rewarding really really
hard and really like confusing and
that's why ship station has been such an
important part of that process because
it simplifies it just takes that one
thing and make that big hard task and
makes it simple all in one place yep
it just makes life a little easier would
we be without ship station it's what we
use here it's what we use a tiger belly
it's hard as like my like merch business
grows with the sunglasses the socks and
the shirts uh you can get them at
annieleterman.com uh Slash merch but
um it is hard because you got to ship
all these different things out and ship
station is very helpful and convenient
and yeah and whether you're starting
small or scaling up ship station makes
ship happen no more limiting your
business to one store ship station
integrates with every platform including
Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify making it
really easy to manage all of your
shipping from one simple dashboard and
you guys can go to shiftstation.com
today and sign up with promo code trash
Tuesday for a free 60-day trial start
today and get set up before the biggest
shipping season of the year that's two
months free visit shipstation.com Click
the microphone at the top and type in
code trash Tuesday
I've recently come across like an
interaction
um in real time of how sugar babies ask
to be sugar-babied I'm so intrigued by
it um so I have a friend who is like you
know he does well for himself and
whatnot he meets a girl actually at a at
a at a friend's party but she was
brought in as like a date it was a
friend's themed party she was Phoebe
they just happened to talk they had and
then they hooked up later that night and
then they parted ways to exchanged
numbers but then the next day she was
like SB just as oh hold on SD question
mark and he was like like San Diego like
is that where you're gonna be you know
and um she was like oh no like you know
just so you know like this is usually
like how it works blah blah blah and she
was like just wanted to know if you
wanted to you know be my sugar daddy
like very direct very polite very bright
and I was like wow they're just outward
there's no trying to be coy about it
it's just SD starting down is the this
I like that there's like code language
for it yeah there is I'm so on board I
could do a whole seminar on dating down
I just have years and years and years I
get dating fat I can tell you what is
dating up I don't understand it's like a
weird thing I guess the guys that I've
dated could relate
I'm gonna text Dave SD question and then
again
can you actually text him SD right now
yeah let's see what he does oh he's
going to be I think San Diego right like
you guys are these things you want to do
a day trip let's see I have never in my
life suggested a day trip so let's sorry
I don't know she's canceled a few
together for 10 years I've never let's
Okay SD question mark can you guys start
this challenge with your listeners like
because I just yes I think you'll get a
lot of suck dick which is funny yes
you just got a question yeah what should
I say back wait it out I'll just no put
something in there so there's a three
dots for like five minutes that's that
is cruel
can you react to yours or he wrote a
question he wrote question mark and then
he just wrote what's that look it up you
tell me yeah yeah you tell me you tell
me
yeah do you tell me I feel like you've
already asked him this and he's already
politely said no yeah many times many
many many times
wait if he Googles it what will happen
let me see SD wait is it not polite to
ask my ex to be my sugar daddy
oh my God to text Bobby
I want to text Bobby right now SD I
think guys would be flattered by it
they'd be like oh you think I'm rich
he'd probably be relieved that it wasn't
sucked up the only the only guys that
are crying about gold diggers are the
guys with no gold today for that like
that's it guys who actually have gold
they're happy to yeah it's weird that's
part of that gold digging is not one wet
you can't one-way gold digger that's
robbing someone yeah every once in a
while I'll get a DM of and I I mean I
don't think that they're like troll
accounts like real DMS from just random
guys like can I be your sugar daddy but
it's like you look so broke
I make more money than you like I got a
lot of people that want to be my sugar
baby but I have my own sugar baby your
sugar babe right I have an update from
Dave he said what's that I said LOL I'm
asking you to be my sugar daddy he said
oh God and then he said can I just be
your husband oh I'm gonna write no no
it's weird that you said once uh you
said yes once and no for so many years
after I know it is true like just like
sexting for you I wish no I literally
begged Dave to marry me every day the
first for five years and then he finally
proposed to me now I have the power and
I'm just like not I won't marry him
basically Dave had his bachelor party
five years ago yeah you guys aren't
married no okay I'm my marriage is
funner yeah also I'm too lazy to plan a
wedding it's just like when you're ready
to have a wedding you're going to be
like excited yeah exactly you're in
about 2 A.M wedding yes sleepover when
you get the right pajamas
You're Gonna Be Ready To Roll you're
gonna be the only one who like does not
have hair and makeup
that's the rule do you take your hair
and makeup off yeah do you watch The
Bachelorette at all yes yes did you
watch it last night no I didn't I
started watching and I fell asleep I'm
okay with spoilers this is gonna come
out for a while because well it's not
even spoilers because everyone's good
card finale so it's they didn't even
give us really a finale so there's a
whole other week oh okay so it was
really anticlimactic but it's just crazy
both of these women are like begging
these men to propose to that and it's so
wild because the men I'm not being like
a you know on the man's side but they
seem logical and rational right because
they're like I want to date you I want
to be with you yeah I'm sure about you
I'm in love with you or I'm falling in
love with you I just don't want to
propose after six weeks but what girls
have to like beg and just you're hearing
the producers in their air like this is
the show the show has to end with the
proposal it's crazy and it's interesting
because I don't know if you saw with
Gabby Gabby's a a friend of the show
love Gabby oh my God love her [ __ ]
[ __ ] I went to follow her because I
watched last season I was like she's
hilarious yeah so I went to father and
she was already following me and I was
like oh my God yes Mitch I think she was
a girl code fan but so so she um and now
she's on Dancing With the Stars with Val
is her partner who's our friend from we
met through Whitney Whitney I know that
she was on but so she said to the one
guy she goes when the guy was going it's
just like this just is isn't realistic
she went she actually went yeah I know
can you just pretend for a second like I
think they're just like can we just have
like a positive outcome because I like
at this point it's like so many of the
people get engaged they don't end up
getting married they have a year of
making a lot of money it happens to just
promise rings is Neil Lane is that
they've done it a couple times
okay they need to like they're the
original they need to set themselves
apart people want this proposal but I
feel like over time we've all realized
how ridiculous it is and so many dating
shows that I love like I loved fuckboy
Island and too hot to handle like they
don't need to end in marriage because
it's just so unrealistic yeah so it just
is sad to watch these girls look
desperate for a proposal after six weeks
or two months or however long they're on
there and the guys are come across so
like Hey listen I really like it yeah I
wonder how much production well they are
like cool kind of production for this
all over for the stuff and I definitely
do that's so sad well um with um what's
the other girl's name I forgot just
first Rachel Rachel Rachel
she always says like when things are
happening she's always like I'm trying
to do a good job as a bachelorette so
what I'm getting from that is like they
want like the outcome to look positive
like they want to get the it's a game
show and they want to win the end of the
game show and so I don't know how much
of it is like this natural like they
don't seem like desperate girls like
Gabby is the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah for sure
but they've been so brainwashed I mean
the way that show is so wild like you
don't have your phone or books or TV
you're just like in this crazy bubble
but
um Zach who's like at the end yes and
they think he's gonna be the next
Bachelor there's no way Zack's the next
best I'm in Cancun and like you met him
and you like DM me late night and he was
like he was like he said SD yeah and I
was like you want to suck my dick
he wanted me to be a sure like I
actually have a dick on the top of my uh
ass crack right now I actually have a
Pilon Idol cyst could you see it at the
point the juice out of it
please help so we did this we had a show
for JFL in Cancun and we did it at the
pool it was like full-blown MTV Spring
Break and he was like one of the single
guys in the pool and we brought guys up
on stage and we brought like three guys
up on stage and then I did like a [ __ ]
Mary kill with all yeah and they we had
him do stuff like I think he kind of
like pulled my hair and like choked me a
little whatever like funny play stuff
and um I chose him to [ __ ] obviously
like of the three guys who and he's I
think he's hotter than he looks on TV I
think everybody is like that but
um he was really hot and he was cool and
then at one in the morning I like just
take it off my makeup and he dm'd me hey
it's [ __ ] do you want to get a drink
that's funny that is funny and I it was
nice I was like if you had the the pool
was three p.m Zach like you've had all
this time yeah to hit me up like I would
have been interested and get a drink
where it's in the hotel bar like it's
one o'clock in the morning so I was like
I just you know it was awesome
seriously that works for me sometimes it
was a cute opener yeah I I I hooked up
with one guy because he he begged me on
that way out he goes I'm leaving he goes
he goes come on let me just just sit on
my face I'm leaving in like in a day and
I was like okay and then we had a
birthday and then it was like he was
leaving so I was like oh yeah I'm sorry
yeah that was fun but I made him do too
much ketamine pretended on being too we
had like a really intense like
conversation about our lives we should
we start SF sit on face sit on face
people are like San Francisco
open for interpretation we're either
going up north or down south or sugar
father Sugar Sugar father that sister
like 80 and above that's like we're not
like Father time we're not [ __ ] but
you're yeah right right right that's
like Hugh Hefner or like decrepit status
yeah it's just enough to like go out to
dinner and look pretty I'm glad you're
you're saying that about him being like
hotter in person too because Hugh Hefner
the edits yes Hugh Hefner gorgeous now
how have you seen him recently was a
board let's exhume him
um but because on The Bachelor and The
Bachelorette people get weird edits they
they do like you know crazy things or
whatever and this season I don't know if
you guys know it's like they don't
usually have two bachelorettes it's like
right like they just pit and they're
thank God these girls are [ __ ]
friends a hundred percent because they
just pit these [ __ ] against each
other completely different personalities
completely different looks and then the
guys got to kind of choose which one it
was just so like they took their power
from them in a way I think they handled
it well but it's like I can see where
they're like I want like these people
but but so like that guy Zach
he was like really thought he was going
to marry he was like ready to marry this
girl I think he I think he's just like
this is fine like I don't think he's a
real deep thinker I think he's just like
she's hot and she seems great and let's
do it would you see hometowns when his
uncle is that like famous guy yeah he
was on Seinfeld yes he was um does he
play the Elaine's boss or somebody
whatever but anyway that's so funny to
like name drop your uncle and like who
brings their Uncle to the [ __ ]
hometowns but um
but yeah so anyway so he like
he was like she's being fake she's being
weird or whatever it's like Yeah because
it is a weird thing yeah but it's
interesting how much people bring to the
front of the camera I was thinking
behind he's he's a nice guy he's like I
I could see a world and he's definitely
like the old school prototype of the
bachelor in terms of just like he just
seemed weak I don't know yeah he seemed
too weak we've already had too many weak
Bachelors no I don't I'm not really
pushing for it I don't know I don't I
think I want him to do too now I feel
like it's only fair I think the hottest
have wood yes they have them do too and
have the women between them I think the
hottest almost Bachelor was on Rachel's
season
um black Rachel mm-hmm
oh never mind he wasn't on that um his
name was Peter he had a little Gap yes
the doctor or something my number one
yes so hot no I keep seeing him on right
yeah is he on Ryan just no that's pilot
pilot Peter
Carlos
he was a weird problem no
he's a trainer he's a trainer that's
what he is no
k-r-a-u-s-s-e is his last name he's not
the bachelor he was on The Bachelorette
it was on The Bachelor and he had the
little Gap too like yes yeah it was hot
with their breakup scene was so
heartbreaking for me it felt real she
cried her lashes off it was that was one
of the most
he's so great he is cute it's like a
different kind of cute but he's salt and
pepper Now esther yeah this is that
that's his like audition picture but
yeah he's no he's so I talk about him
all the time it kind of has like a hot
mouth really hot yes
my mouths are maybe like my number one
feature I look at like lips are so
important no I have a serious like a
skinny lip this sounds like a lot this
sounds like a fake question this is real
when you saw it the first new it here
with the Skarsgard as it like did you
the movie Yes and the juicy lips can you
pull it well I do assume I've seen it I
don't think well just look at this
picture okay okay because all I thought
through this whole [ __ ] movie was
like I would love to get eaten out not
that one
a new one buy that totally
scary clown Troopers scare me
I can get it he can get it and he has a
little bit of a lazy eye and for some
reason the lazy eye was hot but I'm
telling you I was just like oh this is
Juicy like especially that angle you're
like looking down on him like I picture
him between my legs like that's my
period on his nose
he's like I'll get my Red Wings [ __ ]
so hot I think
but as regular Skarsgard I'm like huh
really like Jack Nicholson yeah he's too
like dainty pretty I love all the scars
guards I saw Alexander Skarsgard twice
me too
um we had we locked eyes at a party one
time for more than three seconds
um and then at Oaks Cafe we locked eyes
again and I think he remembered me and
then my niece was like I swear to you he
like like really really looked at you
and then he jumped into like a really
beat up Nissan like Centra or something
like that turns out it was just a
homeless man he was a homeless man had
good ABS can you look up if he's dating
anyone yeah I already looked up it's a
German model so it turns out I am not
his type I imagine
he's always like the the like
wife abuser from big little lies
and they killed him but True Blood he's
so hot True Blood wait was he hotter in
person incredibly hot only because he
seemed like a guy gorgeous everyone's
hotter and shorter I feel like no he
wasn't short and he was commanding the
room Alexa Chung is his ex and he was
commanding the room kalila you are
you're yeah his new girlfriend is like a
German supermodel that gets so old so
fast yeah come on the girls they get too
old but Alexa Chung I mean she's just an
icon yeah so I was at a yeah I was at a
party with him and I was I was dating
this guy who was like commitment phobic
and like not wanting people to know we
were dating and he was like like a short
not that attractive guy and we went to
meet with his friend and it was like
we're dating like we [ __ ] before we
went there we go to this party and his
friend kept trying to set me up with
Alexander Skarsgard and it was just so
funny I just kept looking like do you
guys like other people think I should be
with him
you want to give you like a secret
you're with me
like do you understand
do you understand a person who loves you
thinks there's no way I'm [ __ ] you
and wants me to [ __ ] the model man you
[ __ ] Tarzan
Ashley I think he just brought up a
really good point because I think he is
not as hot to me since big little lies
because he's so evil and such a [ __ ]
head that he wasn't hot he made him not
hot anymore you know like that's that he
is that character he did such a good job
with it yeah he's so talented watched a
Northman okay okay it'll undo big little
lies for you yeah it was a dark dark
movie it's the same guy who did the
lighthouse with Willem Dafoe
um but um yeah super he looked like a
[ __ ] Viking in this one all right
we're taking a Skarsgard card okay
is kalila gonna [ __ ] Alexander oh I love
this
we don't know what any of them Carlos
has to look at me yeah we never
the center of the pile
okay
what is it Six of Swords it's a man that
looks like Freddie Mercury dancing on a
stripper pole that's a really good guy
he's gay oh my God we could be out of
them yeah
what does that mean for dating Valerie
has six penises
enough for everyone in the room six inch
sword I'll take a six oh a six's husband
dick all the way it represents
overcoming obstacles and moving forward
he's done with that [ __ ] he's ready for
you he's not moving forward you've
overcome hardship kalila and healing is
headed your way calmer waters are
finally ahead well he's very calm he's
gonna beat you like Nicole Kidman but
other than that look that is that kid to
play Joffrey was like everyone hates me
poor kid yeah or
I just remember an actress having to
come out
and say like hey that's I'm not that
character yeah like can we separate
well that's what happened she was
getting like who was it was it on
insecure I don't know she was like I'm
um do you understand how like right what
if I did that for the show where I
played myself I'm like for this podcast
I'm like that wasn't me they're like
your character's name was Esther and you
wrote it
no no no
um
yeah did I tell you guys that the guy
who plays Freddy Krueger lives in
um Santa Fe New Mexico and I used to
live there do we know the guy who plays
I can't remember what his name is will
you look it up Robert England okay so
and what he'll do is like you can
recognize him like he does kind of look
like Freddy Krueger but so people when
he would be in line
people would be like Whispering about
Freddy Krueger and he would turn around
and go
oh my God that's so funny yeah he's the
best look at her he's the best I have an
update text from Dave it says I thought
I thought SD was the initials of a place
you wanted to go for dinner tonight and
I couldn't figure it out anyways he had
High Hopes everybody has to do this
track and see yeah because I some guys
will just take it different they'll take
a different direction yeah so cute if
you guys are watching we please text
this to your someone in your life and
tag us and let us know what happens
yeah he's a math teacher in Houston at
an elementary school but he's gone viral
it's kind of like an older influencer
and I love these older influencers are I
heard about this one Grandma who's like
cooking and she's blowing up I kind of
like this movement too yeah there's a
company called I think it's like OAS
they always have these types of models
I think he's probably a model for them I
feel like my dad not as like a model but
as like a Kind of a Funny character
could do it but it's like I would have
to do all the work I used to have this
Instagram account that got pretty big
called fashion dads and it was like dads
people would submit pictures of their
dads and I my dad was on it too and I
would write the captions in a fashiony
way like the way the fashion phones
would write it it was like very that
sounds so nice but were they fashionable
or just like dads it was like Dad
fashion like New Balances yes like like
Esther my favorite such dad shoes I love
these yeah those are the dad shoes of
2022. you guys I've been sleeping on a
helix pillow for the last like three
months I love it so much it's so good
can I say something yes every person in
my family has been gifted a helix
mattress this is not an exaggeration I
mean everybody if it's someone's
birthday they've gotten a helix mattress
for me only because it's like why
wouldn't I share the joy of sleeping on
the most comfortable mattress I've ever
slept on I mean we spend eight hours
out of our 24 over the vertical on
enough vertical hopefully not vertical
horizontal on a bed it's like why
wouldn't you choose the best thing
have the Helix mattress in my guest
bedroom and literally me and Dave fight
I'm like we need to move it into our
main room because it is so good Carlos
has slept on the Helix and the guess do
you love it it's yeah back doesn't hurt
I'm so happy that Helix is our sponsor
only because like I am a legitimate fan
my favorite thing about Helix is their
sleep quiz so you fill out a quiz and it
it basically prescribes you a mattress
that is right for you based on how you
sleep so there's no guessing games it's
not like I have to learn some crazy
system I don't understand it's like no
they ask you the right questions you
tell them and they know what mattress
will just like make your life better for
example I run a little bit hot when I
sleep and I'm a side sleeper so I got
prescribed the midnight and I I'm
obsessed best and Helix is awesome but
you don't need to take our word for It
Felix was awarded number one best
overall mattress pick in 2021 by GQ and
Wired Magazine everybody's unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses that are great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot great
for spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers oh and
they have the option to go Lux so you
have the standard mattress which is
incredible but then you have the option
for an even like thicker mattress that
is so wonderfully freaking locks they
call it Lux do they have a Lex option
where you can just punch you can just
punch it
they also have a 10-year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free and they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
literally will and I just like that
there's really no risk involved in
getting this mattress you guys Helix is
offering up to 200 off of all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com trash
Tuesday that's Helix sleep.com trash
Tuesday
my favorite Tick Tock account
is one called Dad advice from Beau and
it's just this cute little Dad giving
advice on how to like
um change your light switch how to do a
car trade-in oh is that the thing for
boys that don't have dads is that one if
for me it really hits home because I um
I have my dad has perished so like tiny
little things like that it's so warm
when you say Parish it makes it sound
like he I was lost at sea yeah or that
like the like a wind blew and his ashes
he's like well yeah I we threw his Ashes
In The Wind we were like where's that
where's that going but that's um but
that advice from Bo is this Tick Tock no
but it's the same thing oh okay where
did you
um
where'd you spot his ashes in the sea
um we he came this is when my when my
dad died I was 19.
um we didn't have a lot of money then
and they gave us an option he wanted to
be cremated so we cremated him but I
don't know if you guys have see the tear
of your options your box options
um if you don't want to pay the extra 35
he basically comes in like a to-go box
and that's exactly what he came in is a
to-go box
and so we were like did you have a
little nibble
um I
like the bag thank you for coming
yes is there fan on this no it's really
what they handed us how many sets of
silverware and they guilt you they
really guilt you because they're like
okay so this is a 3 500
urn but if you don't love him you can
also just take him in this plastic bag
oh my gosh and so you know we kind of
like not look this guy in the eye we're
like we'll just take that one thank you
and then we left spread them my ex
boyfriend had like a little like I guess
they split the dad's ashes up I don't
know if they spread some of them but he
had like a little urn I just kept like
being like is there a world where I'm
accidentally yoniagging this [ __ ] I
mean it was like Yogi exercise I was
like well Queen banana break because we
finished
foreign
we did a banana eating contest it was
wild was it hot like watch these girls
just deep throw these bananas oh like to
see who does it was it like the stars
that already do that or there's a girl
some audience oh that's I find that on
the live show men's capacity for taking
this down the hatch is far more
um you know what I mean impressive that
yeah yeah ours is like maybe to here
they can take this whole thing
okay so in my like hypnosis Journey
there's one there's hypnosis downloads
as a place I go and I don't have my like
personal hypnotist that made a specific
thing for me and I need it you can go in
and you can like get different hypnosis
uh
um recordings for different things and I
was just scrolling through and they have
one for gag reflex hmm
I wonder who invented that asked you
um
um I do to that I say a gag reflex is
what you need guys are into the whole
sound of you
rejecting your throat
we've been here before I don't want to
repeat stories but we've all thrown up
on it and get spit is so much better of
a lubricant than just regular saliva so
it's like they I don't want to get rid
of them can we like discuss this yes so
when we we had Asa Akira on ours I love
her she's a friend of mine okay and I
love her [ __ ] no no she like made me
want to do porn like the way she talks
about getting into porn is so inspiring
it was really like find your passion and
like do it for your career and she was
we I like I was obsessed with her I was
like attracted her she's like I'm
straight I'm like this is the
straightest person so embarrassing but I
just found her to be like so wonderful
in every way but she said her [ __ ]
tip was that like deep gagging spit but
this is like so gross but isn't that
just like your like Lucy Smith yeah it's
like your gastrointestinal like your
stomach acids okay
um I was thinking of like phlegm I'm
like are we we're not lubing up with
like phlegm but phlegm that's like when
it's combined with like nose juice right
like to me that's like boogery
ear nose and throat yeah like well where
you swallow is opposite from your
trachea and your windpipe so
um when you're swallowing your trachea
is closed so if it cannot be phlegm
because the phlegm would come from your
lungs
um if your mouth is open and it's coming
from that end it's more likely to come
from your stomach so it's a mixture of
probably hydrochloric acid and a bunch
of other stuff that you just ate getting
kicked back up okay which makes it even
grosser to me 3.5 Chinese food
but I'm so glad you brought up ASA I
think grab soup baby she's a perfect
example of
um
um being hypersexual being very
business-minded about it yeah and just
kind of doing it all right and plus
she's so [ __ ] funny and Brilliant and
can do anything I just I'm in love with
her yeah she's it just was such an I've
never I mean I haven't talked to a ton
of porn stars but the way and I'm I know
not everyone has the same experience but
her experience was like pretty good and
she was just like
I like having sex it was like fun with
an audience right decided we had the
anal version of that on our show right
we had Stella Berry on and you know I
was just like oh my goodness they really
are it was a breath of fresh air the
healthiest guest we've ever had yeah
yeah it's fun to like learn about that I
know there's so many haters though about
it like so many sex worker haters but
we're just like we don't care we like
sex workers and the people that hate sex
workers also probably like sex workers
it's like they just don't want them to
like it they don't want them to be happy
about it yeah like when you're
homophobic you're like you're the gayest
person yeah you're just so good well
that's what Stella says it's like like
Mike Pence is the gayest person like
there's just no he gets bro talks it
doesn't want to have and he doesn't have
lunch with women he had no [ __ ]
because you don't want to yeah I have
something from HBO last week about the
problem with young men nowadays
um oh I think I saw this
yes oh my God okay so Scott Galloway is
like my dream zaddy just so yeah all
right here you go
we have we have a crisis among young men
and it starts at a young age young men
are twice as likely on a
behavior-adjusted basis to be suspended
seven and ten high school valedictorians
or women for every one female for every
two female graduates from college the
next five years you only have one the
scariest stat walking down the Avenue
that is America only one in three men
under the age of 30 have had sex in the
last year and you hear sex and your
brain fires but the bottom line is it's
a key step to the elemental Foundation
of any society and that is relationships
men young men aren't attaching to work
they aren't attaching to women they
aren't attaching to schools we are
producing too many of the most dangerous
person in society and we are losing out
on a key we're not going to have kids
we're not going to have a productive
Society we're gonna have more violence
and also we're going to have a society
that does not value uh young men and
they do not young men are different they
develop later and by the way if you're a
young man this work from home thing is a
disaster they need Young man young man
young many guard rails they need to know
how to read a room they need to put on a
clean shirt they know not to get high or
drink too much during the week sounds
like and then get into the off office
the next day we have a crisis among
young men it is it is it is it is one of
the most in my view one of the most
dangerous things in our society wait
does it keep going there's something
else that he says that um I think also
Carlos did you just for it did you just
do a little first equation no because I
thought her left eye up because thank
you
because so you sometimes you you asked
about the phone simply put it's a
disaster whenever technology comes into
an industry consolidates it mating has
been Consolidated in the worst way 50
men on Tinder 50 women 46 of the women
show all of their attention to just four
men leaving 46 men
pursuing just four women if if mating
was a country it would be more unequal
than Venezuela we have huge mating
inequality and here's the problem when
people don't get together and there's no
pheromones and there's no vibe women and
we don't like to say this on the left
primarily try and make very quick
assumptions about this individual's
ability to Garner resources in the
future so what you have is this
concentration of interest and you're
ending up with Porsche polygamy where 10
of the men get 90 percent of the
attention which does not lead to good
behavior well I was the girl banging the
other guys so I was doing God's work
I'm scared I I it I mean it's almost
like yeah I already I didn't need to
hear it I already knew it like there are
you feel it yeah you feel it in the
culture especially like being women on
camera and you know like sharing our
opinions every week
but it it's sad and I'm like what do we
do do we just have to [ __ ] all these
losers like how do we get out of this
dude I've done my [ __ ] quota of losers
I'm done okay and then everyone gets mad
at me for that all these [ __ ] Facebook I
think I've been extra charitable to
Algos my whole life
I'm the tax write-off [ __ ]
discount in the future me too I thought
that I was gonna get some social
discount at some point in my life and
say you know what maybe the men will be
nice to me because I have just [ __ ]
uggles my whole life turns out that's
not the case wait you're on to something
I think we should start like get a
lobbyist and I think we should get tax
write-offs or tax rebates for [ __ ]
sad young men right I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna do it
[Applause]
I just I'm sorry I'm like now I I'm just
really in my head about all that stuff I
mean it's just I it's not like such hot
takes but it's
it's it is so scary it's like women
don't
have a lack of structure and have lack
of sex and even lack of education and
are violent in retaliation like it's
just it's all bad and he made such a
good point about the working from home
thing like they need to be in the world
and like socialize and we keep hearing
this sometimes on our podcast about this
the not having sex I mean I that stat
sounded crazy to me of three men under
30 and one has had sex is that what he
said yes well imagine too how much covid
made that worse yeah because if you're
not in high school like seeing people
and and like getting energy and from
people you're not gonna [ __ ] like
um
and I there's just so many different
things I mean I think that there are
still so many women in the world that
just don't want to do apps and want to
meet people in the wild and I think it's
so so many guys that would never dream
of approaching a woman and I don't know
there's a lot and then some of the ones
that do I think you know let's just say
Britney Snow and then broke up no with
Tyler from selling because of the
Scandal
what wait what happened
because no
no wait what was going on are you guys
watching this show listen I don't even
know the show but I know the drama from
last week where he was he like outed one
of the other girls for trying to kiss
him trying to make out with him twice
off camera did you saw that part yeah
I've watched the whole I binge the whole
series but she was saying she was
getting mixed messages from him so how
is Brittany Snow not gonna go like
were you giving mixed messages why would
a girl think they could lean and kiss a
married guy wait they're married
yeah so they're married and
this all the women that that's you know
it's all women in this real estate
office and then three guys and so he
they all flirt with him
but he he flirts back one of them was
hitting on him like propositioning him
to sleep with her and he said no he was
like I'm married yeah I mean they didn't
show the actual encounter but they spoke
about it and they they talked about it
afterwards she apologized him and he was
like you know I felt uncomfortable I
married this girl Alex Hall and him are
very flirty and she's kind of
alluded to having a crush on him and she
like gets in his face and like sucks his
nose it's weird I don't know I never
heard of this and I'm the girl in the
middle that but yes Kayla guys I'm
obsessed with the show and I binge did I
get but it seems like that there had to
be like problems before
they didn't they there's no way this
like show I mean maybe maybe I mean if a
honestly if a girl sucks Dave's nose I'm
out that is horrible I would rather see
him [ __ ] someone else again no suck that
is so intimate we're jealous and it was
like why are you sucking my nose I have
a cute butt like they're in like a
cuddle pile on the beach like I see I
mean that's the this that is weird it's
just not
right I mean I get it but don't you
think that you would know if his wife
embarrassment too though like for her
that yeah are like messaging her and
being like your husband's cheating like
that sucks and then there was this weird
moment where one of the other guys from
the show was like so you were away for a
while you guys like you know [ __ ] to
make up for it he didn't say those words
but that's what I would say and he he
kind of stumbled on and he was like no
we're not really having sex like it was
a little weird and then the other guy
just assumed because he like was having
some erectile problems and like took it
and ran with that but it was a weird
moment so it does make me think that
they were having problems before If he
if he got asked if they were having sex
yeah and he stumbled yeah
just to go back to the really scary
thing we were just talking about from
Scott Galloway I have I want to give it
a positive spin okay I think that our
show
is so clearly we are 50 50 men and women
for our listeners so I think that we are
like
we're we're starting this to solve the
problem right here today many boys like
oh I forgot a boy slug I wanted to shout
out
um
[Music]
my boy it was I I want to tell you the
slugs come through and the moments I
need them I was in Atlantic City with my
boyfriend and his friend his friend's
like I gotta meet this girl at a club
will you come with me I don't want to go
to the club right but I'm like of course
I'll go along for the party
there's a line we're going to pay 20
bucks I'm like oh
Danny Danny comes up he goes oh my God
are you Annie Letterman freaks out gets
me right into the club gets us right in
and I was like I will show you and I
forgot but we went to Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang on Danny thank you I forgot your
name wrong sorry but you're in my heart
I I love that you guys have the audience
like that I can't relate even my
Instagram followers 97 women it's like
no I would love that too I mean the
girls are amazing too it's like I think
I started out with so many male
followers because I did like Opie and
Anthony back in the day and like all the
guy things that I did
so to get girls is like a [ __ ] dream
I mean yeah it's amazing yeah but it is
fun to have both and the boys are always
like they're like I feel like I'm
learning to be like a better boyfriend
yes it's it's like so heartwarming like
I hate to give men so much credit but
the men that email us and say like
listen to your podcast help me change
change my relationship or my the way I
view women or sex or whatever and we
don't really get like single guys at our
shows every once in a while we do and I
will try to [ __ ] them
um it's like one of my favorite stories
is this guy I [ __ ] after one of our
shows
um but will you tell us yeah oh yeah but
women are bringing their boyfriends more
we notice that like Post covid Yeah like
for whatever reason
um but yeah this this girl brought her
guy friend to our show in uh SD
um we brought him up on stage and he and
I were really flirty and uh
I was like do you wanna I was like very
into it I was like do you want to
connect after the show I was like do you
have Instagram I was just thinking I
would DM him and he was like no I don't
I was like that's so awesome so or
you're married I was like when you leave
the stage just leave your number with
our assistant she sits on the side of
the stage and like controls the show and
like the presentation and everything I
was like I feel like a male comedian I
feel like this is what they get to do
they're like leave the number with my
assistant and so we go back down in the
Green Room afterwards and I was like I
want to connect with that guy he was
super hot he was cool and we were
flirting on stage and a couple
girlfriends who had been to the show
come in and they're like he's up there
and all of the girls are swarming him I
was like [ __ ] like how disrespectful
you knew he was mine I'm just kidding
but I was like the disrespect I was like
someone just could go get him so our
like assistant actually she outsourced
it to this like Live Nation rep I was
like what is going on here this is now I
feel like an athlete now I feel like
it's like go get the go get that hot
person that was like sitting you know
Courtside and bring him down here so he
she they went and got him and brought
him down and uh it was like immediate
chemistry we were just like flirting
right now was like taking all these
photos of these cute photos of us like
in the green room and we ended up going
back to the hotel and uh had like a
great sexual experience and then he was
in California for the week and we went
to LA after we were in San Diego and he
drove to LA
and it was great I mean that was really
what it was it was just a fling and I I
got some really good material out of it
yeah I did one but I don't talk about on
stage because I don't I mean now I'm in
a relationship but it's like I I was
like I never wanted to break that seal
because I would get guys coming up that
would just hover I'm like you came to
[ __ ] me like you really came to my
stand-up show I've been doing this for
13 years busting my ass got funny as
[ __ ] and you came to [ __ ] me well
there's another guy that was on the same
trip then we go to San Francisco and
this guy is I'm not like scared I think
he's harmless but he DMS me every day
like and he he's just talking to himself
for years he's wrote In Love Letters
that come to our joint emails like
Reyna's read them it's so mortifying you
know and he's just obsessed with me he's
just like middle-aged little man you
know and he came to the San Francisco
show and at the very end of the show so
I knew he was coming like I because he I
don't I forget why I knew he was coming
and I was like I just told the venue
like can you just keep an eye out like I
just I'm not scared but I just don't
know what he's gonna do and I couldn't
spot him the whole show and at the end
of the show rays were like doing our
toast and all the music's going off he
came up to the stage and he dropped this
like box on the stage
it was this like jewelry box
and
I wish I have the photo but it basically
had like a room key to his hotel and it
said something like I want to eat your
ass tonight
he texted you yeah he can eat it now
with what is going on back there but
yeah so it goes that was all like in the
same week but it goes both ways no the
conversations themselves I turned my DMs
off I can't even I can't do that like
it's always unread but I like see it at
the top like I don't I don't know I
guess I could like block him but I don't
open it I don't know yeah it's just like
a weird thing I'm just so psyched that
you like got that moment where you got
to say leave my number with my assistant
and you got to seek him out like I've
never ever done that I've and I've but
I've seen so many men do that over the
years so I'm just like so thankful that
you did that for all of us it was funny
because then she
I was like our assistant's name Bella I
was like text him to make sure it's like
uh like his number and she like responds
back from the side of stage she's like
it turned green and the all audience is
like
like booing his Android like it was just
very funny it was his number you're like
it's a fling guys he can have an Android
okay I was like that Green Tech stick
but then you can't but then you can't
um FaceTime I hooked up the guy book was
so hot like I couldn't resist like I had
the rule in my head I was like I'm not
hooking up with fans order but he was
from New Zealand he was so hot he was so
ripped there's a picture that he sent me
on an old phone that's gone I I'm in
love I I met my person but God damn was
that picture impressive I was like oh
you still have it
what was the picture of it was just him
and a towel
in like a locker room it was just he was
one of the hottest guys I have ever seen
in my life but he was like a fan yes he
was a fan and then he came I like talked
to I did crowd work with him and then he
came like hung out and then
I was like he was the one that was like
just let me sit on like or sit on my
face please like what if it was like can
I sit on your face like no no just let
me teabag you come on
um before I go but um I had him come to
The Comedy Store and I had like my
friends with me and they were like he is
precious like you've got to yeah all of
us I mean funny we stayed friends he was
a nice guy one of our like main stories
in the podcast that the listeners are so
invested in this was over a year ago now
but for a while they were on this like
CIA mission was I did meet this guy
crowd working him I I have the video
It's Like on Tick Tock and Instagram
people love to watch it because you
watch it happen in real time of me like
what who is this guy is he a plant he's
here alone he's single he's tall he's
drinking Martini like what is going on
and after the show we met up and we
ended up like going to dinner at
midnight at little Frankie's in New York
like we shut the place down we came back
to my house we were like making out it
was like this epic night and I was like
this is
like I mean he was a lot younger but I
was just like I'm like very much vibing
and I feel like he's really vibing with
me and I know what it feels like to be
with somebody you're like you're never
gonna hear from him again and I just
didn't feel like that and gave him my
number didn't even think to like get his
I was like he's probably gonna text me
like as soon as he walks out the door
you know like I'm this is it and never
heard from him again and and I don't
know his last name I had them like just
for my then everyone was on this mission
of like what possibly could have
happened I know it's so weird was he
lying about something and then I checked
the ticket sales from the show and like
what his what his first name allegedly
was he wasn't on there and then he had
told me that he had come to the show
because this comedian named Natalie
Cuomo he knew her from college and she
it was her show and then she didn't know
him like it was wild it was like all
these check obituaries like he must have
died well I don't even have his I don't
have his last name like yeah I've never
not been able to find somebody calling
the hospital is there a hot guy there I
have a positive
he had a nice watch I have positive take
on this I think leave it because I think
what he gave you is such a gift because
there have been many times where okay
I've had these lines like 12 hours just
like to find his address somehow and
Drive by like friends like I I had this
one one time in Vegas that's 12 hours
just a small window of time we I mean
just the best time I've ever had with a
single person one of those like yeah it
was like a music video like in 12 hours
and at the end of it all I didn't we
didn't exchange numbers I don't know why
I think he has friends exchanged I don't
know it was like 12 years ago and um if
it had ended there it could have gone
down it as it could have just been a
fantasy bubble I would occasionally look
at or remember it be and feel good about
but no I pursued it I found him three
months later and it turned out he turned
out to be one of like the most horrible
people but if I had just left it there
it could have been just this one thing
that I just constantly turned to when
I'm having like a you know blue day I'm
like oh yeah I remember that time that
Rihanna song Stay in the strip club till
10 a.m together me sitting on his lap
you know like all of these things these
memories come flooding and I could have
just not popped the bubble yeah I think
that's I think about that a lot of just
leaving things as this memory like I
[ __ ] our driver in Greece this summer
and I just was like this is just
needs to this is one night yeah you know
we're not gonna keep in touch like I
have a great bit out of it and it's
that's what it was like I think
sometimes we have the tendency to be
like yeah but this is gonna be like my
romance like my yeah yeah we like to
kill our own Joy also like I have the
inside with the Delilah where it's like
you kind of just like end it but then
when they pursue it's kind of hard
because they're like you don't want to
pursue you're like rejecting I had a I
have a insane thing that happened on
this podcast where I I had hooked up
with this guy on a plane he like
fingered me on an airplane no stop it
was at the beginning we just hit it out
he missed his plane
yeah he had like a she he was like he
looked like Channing Tatum he was like
in like sweat shorts that's my number
one but he had like uh he's just the boy
could dance you know you could tell and
he had like he had like a cheek piercing
and he was like in a Sugar Ray cover
band I mean like there was like a lot
happening you know but I was telling the
story about it because we had continued
talking and then he started sending all
these bondage porns where I was like I'm
not gonna get ball gagged by you sir but
we kind of stayed friends or whatever
and then he finally like blocked me
because I started reading his sex on
stage and I guess I hurt his feelings
but the sex was it was too good I read
it on here before 100 it was too good
and and then so I was like Carlos like
pull up a picture of him because there's
all these like shirtless pictures of him
looking so hot from a stupid band and
then Carlos goes he died last week no no
are you serious I found out on camera on
this show we found out he died my finger
band guy died and then I chose this is
not unreal I don't know how he died and
I chose to knock I'm assuming probably
fentanyl has everyone's done for sure
for sure but I like chose to not go to
the memorial service because he blocked
me I wanted to I wanted to respect his
boundary but it's killing me I want to
know what it was I've been post-mortem
that is wild is that crazy yeah how did
like you ended up sitting next to him on
the plane yeah well we like we we had to
walk to a new plane because he had
missed his plane I was on standby and I
didn't get on yeah so then we like
walked to the second plane and like hung
out and stuff and he went up and when I
knew it was gonna happen is he took both
of our licenses and went we're together
and I went I was like stopping what okay
they sat next to me smelled good he like
got up to go to the bathroom his butt
he's like sure he might be like perfect
body was it just was there a third
person in the row yeah there was some
Israeli kid that was kind of just did
you guys start making out sorry I'm very
interested on an airplane oh there was
the blanket it wasn't like he didn't get
up too much you know but it was like it
was like uh to him like to him it was
like the beginning and to me I was like
this is going to be a great story yeah
and then baggage claim he was pulling me
close I was like no no
no
that if someone blocks you that when
they pass away that that expires and
that you're allowed to do whatever you
want I'll have to like check with his
his friends he was like he was like he
was a nice guy he was really into
bondage maybe he [ __ ] choked himself
to death oh my God asphyxiated that
would be so crazy if you went to a
funeral and someone's friends had to be
like you he wouldn't want you here well
I always think like I don't know what
will happen to me once that's my goal I
am not suicidal and I will never it will
never happen but I was saying like I
think one of the like you do want to
leave that mystery of like maybe or I
was jerking off that's the that's the
suicide yeah I was about to come
hit any of these what's the leaving
phone and car full of guys yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah what's the news
um
these girls leave their phone in the car
with a bunch of guys just to see what
they say about that
oh that gives me anxiety I'm not
interested in that yeah yeah I mean like
for myself we can watch the thing okay
yeah my feelings are already hurt it's
just not my business what you say behind
my back that's why the internet's so
annoying it's like why are you singing
in front of my back yeah why are you
saying it to my tits okay
all right here you go
that's on Tick Tock this girl was like
you wanna know what we used to do with
our guy friends in high school if it was
like a car full of people the girls
would be in the backseat they'd be
chatting the guys would drop them off
and one of the girls would leave her
phone in the car recording and then
about five minutes later they would text
the boys and say you need to turn around
one of us forgot our phones and so then
the girls would grab the phone the big
thanks and then they'd go listen to
everything the guys would say after they
dropped them off but they go don't do
this unless you want your feelings
completely hurt how
the [ __ ] up is that oh I was gonna say
it's kind of Genius I honestly right
when I saw that I was like how can I do
this by myself without friends I used to
I was like I want to do this so bad like
yeah that would hurt my feelings I mean
hopefully not my own partner but if
you're like the hottest girl in school
it's probably going to be positive but
it's probably going to be like vulgar
but unfortunately it's the wrong
friend's phone yeah they're like Susan's
so hot Stacy's a [ __ ] pig it's weird
they're friends yeah
Esther Ives you look mad I'm like
because I can't I'm trying to think of a
use for it in my life but I can't think
of one and I'm kind of surprised but I
know there's one like I'm like do I do
it to my parents oh my God yes who do I
I think like honestly edit it out to the
point that's how much I want you to do
your practice I don't want them to know
oh my God make sure
you leave your phone recording that you
caused some type of issue yeah you know
you can't leave peacefully and they're
gonna be like oh she's changed she's so
sweet these days now you have to cause
like a stir I that will happen
organically for sure
um Ashley thank you so much for yeah
thanks for having me coming it's so fun
a part of Bonnie McFarland says hi I was
just talking to her this morning oh I
love her yeah this is so fun and I hope
everyone goes and listens to your hugely
widely crazily popular successful
podcast Girls Gotta Eat thanks and
anywhere else people should be looking
for you yeah Girls Gotta Eat and we also
have a sex toy company with a paired app
called Vibes only so you can check all
that out at fivesonly.com and download
the app for Android and iPhone and Shop
the toys at Vibes only and on all social
media I am Ash Hess yeah here's our
Instagram provides only so we just
introduced a new [ __ ] gel in vanilla
flavor what does it do it's just good to
give a blow job with like it makes it
taste good we have a mango and a vanilla
frosting and people like love it they're
doing it yeah like like around the edge
um and we have a great lube and then we
have three toys we have more coming out
uh for the holidays and then you compare
it with an app that's erratic content so
it like pairs via Bluetooth and then it
pulses along with the stories oh like
the story starts out kind of slow did
you guys create that that's awesome like
taken over our lives but yeah we're
really proud of it
um so it's it's been fun okay one
question just because I'm seeing the
picture what do you guys think of Chris
Pine's uh blonde bob it's like feminine
and kind of a hot way what did he looks
like a baby girl power lesbian like I
but I'm like I am attracted to it I'm
into it I'm so into it like I didn't
know he looked like that now I can't
keep up with all the Chris's
I think he's a great actor yeah I'll
leave it at that
[Laughter]
that's not gonna hurt his feelings we
know I like when he's like yeah no I do
like how it's like look at when he has
the the full um gravy Gray beard gray
hair that's super hot that's scary
actually oh what is your guy's favorite
Chris
he's skinny of all the Christmas what's
what was that was it Pine Evans Evans
does nothing for him I'm the same way
and they were all like he's single and I
was like I'm not interested yeah I mean
I pretended to be but deep down I feel
like he's out there I don't think I
would wait who are the other Chris's
Pine um Hemsworth oh and Pratt Pratt's
Christian sorry yeah but his body that
thick boy body is what I like I do like
a guy who worked out I love his life
right gain fat over the workout body is
the best yeah it works I used to have
dreams he's too wholesome for me I just
really now that I saw the Chris Pine
looking like a yeah I do like baby girl
Chris I liked him looking so annoyed
yeah like during those interviews like
like when Harry Styles was talking to
you just I liked his Vibe right I agreed
I think we all like Chris Pine but a
different version of Chris Pine I like
your striped shirt striped shirt bottom
right
actors are weird guys that looked like
the teacher that molested me literally
that's that's what molested makes I bet
it was full dreads
do you see why I'm upset okay it wasn't
even the judging take it down we
shouldn't have gone you guys thank you
so much we will see you next week for an
all new episode of trash Tuesday we all
can't wait to check out everything that
Ashley has done yeah yes
[Music]
thank you